we're back with the hosts of the talk
and these ladies are
experts when it comes to the art of
thoughtful
lively conversation and we're going to
dive into some hot topics
but not too hot i don't ever want to be
super controversial
um so this is warm topics
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay so a new cosmo article says
that the latest trend
is single people forming opinions about
potential partners
based on only one characteristic and
ruling people out because
they don't like that one quality example
height
anyone have a thought anyone ever been a
monomatic dater
no gotta be open open to all sorts of
people
all different shapes and sizes that's
the most interesting people come
in the most like unexpected ways i found
and it's more about like the soul and
the person and
how interesting they are how passionate
they are how their hands feel against
you
that's a warm topic i didn't go too deep
i do think it's easy
to do that though like it is easy to
read something and be like oh
well you know they do this or something
and write them off right away but
everyone that
you know i've always dated and and
fallen in love with it's because
over time you get to know that person
and then you get to know all the little
best little great little juicy things
about that person no one's perfect you
know
no one's perfect and to go on something
like high
or he he's bald or whatever it's like
they could have the greatest soul in the
world
and you're just letting them go because
they're short or no hair
it's like no i do have the one thing
drew
what if i have the one thing you cannot
date me if you're
already married well now
but nobody ever asks that question and i
tell women
the first thing you ask a man are you
married because a man will say in your
face i'm separated
well do your wife know she's separated
that's why you have to ask
so on your dating profile it will say
sheryl
not a cuckold that's you but i say it
i'm glad you said the word because it's
not going to sound
as dignified as you just said it if i
say it
not to cuckle um i i agree
in this like weird swipey world it's
like
people are just judging on a photo and
amanda i'm so with you like andy warhol
says fall in love with your eyes closed
sharon you're absolutely right and like
i feel like it's getting to know someone
that makes you go you know what like a
plus b equals c
like and on and on and when you're just
looking at a picture and equipping and
by the way all these men on these dating
profiles are so
quippy and like ambiguous like
you can't get to know somebody i will
tell you if i had to meet jonathan
on a swipey swipey app i wouldn't have
swiped he's not my type
in air quotes and i've known him since
we were kids he had these big glasses
and i remember i was not checking for
him
in high school because he had these big
old glasses and
now he i'm so glad i got over that thing
and that i got to meet this man in
person because he is
he's my person and i just think if you
get stuck on the shallow stuff
in the swipe you swipe you're never
going to get to the good stuff yep
but everybody now is stuck on the
shallow
that's why they take pictures of
themselves constantly
so it's like everybody just cares about
the way you look
but but i mean didn't you have a time
where when you were younger
you saw a photograph and went that's a
nice looking guy or that's a guy
i want to meet i don't know if it would
be easy to look at it on a gadget
but i will tell you i've torn out plenty
of pictures
in a magazine and said this is my time
you let lenny kravitz walk up in here
he could get it
i'd like to see that mood board cheryl
and by the way elaine
everything you just said reminded me of
like 13 going on 30.
wow
your story is just it's the dream like
that you have the perspective and you
find the right one okay next topic
jennifer coolidge revealed
that she couldn't decide between two men
on hawaiian vacation
so she pretended to have an identical
twin
and then date both of them and
she dated two guys for a week oh my god
i couldn't believe this story sharon
thoughts uh well firstly i
i adore her she is so funny
and good luck to her whoa i never
thought of doing that ever
and it's way too late to try now but i
think that's a great
idea i think it's interesting holiday
fun it's ingenious
yes yes i could never date two people
at once that's hard have you ever slept
with two people
not at once no i'm like a one-person
kind of person like it's really hard for
me because i'm so committed to things
like i give everything to me
i wouldn't be able to it would it
wouldn't feel right to me could you do
that
i have dated two people at once and it
was fun
[Applause]
like dinner with him and that he like
put me in a taxi and i just went right
around the corner and had drinks with
the next one
did everybody know and was everybody oh
no no no no they don't know
no but i also i also i mean i was not
this was
no one was serious this was not
complicated
i mean you know but uh but yes no it was
fun
it was only a small part of my life but
it was a good time
absolutely absolutely and i try to split
them up in time zones
so it's really not the same day
amanda i did that once too i went to a
lunch with
one gentleman and he ended up kissing me
and then i drove to the next thing and
he ended up kissing me and i was like
wow twofer great day
way to go drew i love it
um i really understand why you guys
have so much fun together and i don't
want to leave right now
i want to stay with you guys this is
something bad
you can always come back come over to us
come over and visit us for all yeah
um actually that no joke can we make
that a date as soon as it is safe
i would love to come visit you guys
we can do this
[Applause]
okay thank you so much to the host of
the talk
i just my goodness okay i guess it's
gotta end
i don't want it to but you know weekdays
on cbs
2 p.m eastern
[Music]
you